[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es mal wieder was leckeres
helfer des türkisches ich mache es so
frank ebert und zwar ist es ein kebab
gericht also ein fleischgericht aus dem
ofen und das ganze wird im juca
eingerollt und gebacken das ganze kennt
man vielleicht auch unterwegs so kenne
ich aus der türkei aber das ist ein
bisschen abgewandelt und wird mit
hähnchenbrust gemacht statt mit linda
kalbfleisch es wirklich super lecker man
kann super zu bereiten und die
zubereitung ist auch gar nicht so schwer
ich benötige dafür 700 gramm
hähnchenbrust 50 milliliter olivenöl
habe ich jeweils zwei paprikaschoten in
rot hellgrün und dunkelgrün die
dunkelgrünen sind scharf 2 zwiebeln salz
pfeffer
ich habe ich ein bisschen berg bohren
kraut ist vergleichbar mit thymian oder
oregano chili für die joghurt soße nehme
ich den joghurt mit zehn prozent fett
stufe 3 knoblauchzehen salz und pfeffer
und wird die butter soßen nehme ich ein
bisschen butter paprikapulver chili und
dann brauche ich nach juba blätter die
könnt ihr entweder selber machen oder
einfach auch fertig schon kaufen und
dann habe ich noch 400 milliliter
hühnerbrühe habe ich auch schon gekocht
und vorbereitet die zwiebeln habe ich
jetzt bereits gewöhnt und jetzt nehme
ich hier die paprika und kann die auch
anderen feine ringe schneiden
wenn ihr es nicht so gerne scharf mögt
dann nehmt keine scharfe paprika dazu
und lass das chili weg aber wir mögen
uns gerne hier alle schafe deswegen
chili und paprika
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich als nächstes das fleisch
schneiden und schneide ich auch in feine
würfel
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich das olivenöl und gebe es
in einem großen topf da kommen jetzt die
zwiebelwürfel mit rein und bei
türkischen rezepten ist es oft so da
werden erst die zwiebelwürfel angebraten
dann kommt die paprika dazu und zum
schluss das fleisch also da macht man
irgendwie keine röstaromen ans fleisch
sondern erstmal an die zwiebeln und als
gemüse
und jetzt die zwiebeln einfach für zwei
bis drei minuten glasig anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt kommt ihr die paprika mit dazu die
kaufe ich übrigens immer im typischen
laden da gibt es immer die spitze picard
in grün und hellgrün und dunkelrot
[Musik]
einfach kurz ein bisschen mit anbraten
und wenn die paprika dann gebraten ist
und lecker duftet dann kommt das fleisch
dazu wird auch mit angebraten
[Musik]
jetzt kocht richtig schön und auch der
fleischsaft tritt aus jetzt kann ich es
würzen mit dem berg wohnung kraut und
chili das ist übrigens das bag wohnung
kraut von meinen eltern aus der türkei
habe jetzt mitgebracht wenn auch bei
unserem garten angepflanzt und jetzt
noch mit salz und pfeffer würzen und
dann kann ich den herd eigentlich
ausstellen und das ganze ganz kurz
abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt die füllung fertig und ich nehme
die lüfterblätter ich habe jetzt
übrigens nicht die aus der verpackung
denn die haben total zusammengeklebt
also darüber wie die falsche marke
gekauft jetzt sind wir einfach zu
unserem dönerladen gefahren vorne zum
viva und der nette junge mann im wasser
liegt und hat uns einfach gemacht dass
mein junge blätter detail geht die kann
man auch selber machen aber ich hole
durch das zeichnen schnell und einfach
das geht also jetzt einmal halbieren
die sind etwas kleiner als die die man
aus der packung kriegt aber ich finde es
hat jetzt die perfekte größe und jetzt
kommt hier jeweils ein bisschen füllung
[Musik]
denn die rente ein schlagen und
vorsichtig auf rollen wie so ein großes
zigarren bürger und dann vorsichtig aufs
backblech legen
[Musik]
und so kommen die gerollten jufra jetzt
in den backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze bisher an der oberfläche
schön knusprig sind und ich werde mir
zwischenzeit schon mal den joghurt
vorbereiten
[Musik]
nämlich den joghurt und da nämlich immer
gerne den 10
die joghurt weil da einfach super cremig
ist geschmacklich ist doch echt toll
den gebe ich jetzt in eine große schale
dann kommen da die knoblauchzehen dazu
ich hoffe mein bruder hat mich da schon
arbeitet am haus denn da haben wir noch
alle gleich nämlich nicht ganze 13
vielleicht nur zwei
und damit salz und pfeffer abschmecken
[Musik]
der joghurt ist bereit den kann ich noch
mal kühl stellen
und dann kommt ja nur noch eigentlich
diese paprika soße und dafür wird die
butter einfach in einem kleinen topf zu
lassen
da kommt das paprika und chili pulver
dazu und dann wird einmal aufgeschäumt
und kommt dann später direkt darüber
jetzt muss ich aber noch aus dem
backofen warten jetzt ist das cache
schön knusprig und jetzt hab ich ja hier
dieser hühnerbrühe und bestreicht
einfach diese rolle denn damit
dadurch wird es wieder ein bisschen
weicher und angenehmer zu essen ich
könnte auch ein tauchen aber ich habe
jetzt ein bisschen länger gerollt oder
kann es auch vorher halbieren und dann
eintauchen
das geht auch
die hühnerbrühe darf auch ruhig kräftig
gewürzt sein so wie es gerne habt
sagt den rest einfach drüber gießen
jetzt ein bisschen einziehen lassen und
ich werde in der zwischenzeit jetzt
schon mal die butter schmelzen und das
paprikapulver und chilipulver dazu geben
[Musik]
und jetzt wird es hier schön in feine
röllchen geschnitten
eigentlich schön mundgerecht dann muss
man nämlich später nichts nachschneiden
am tisch
[Musik]
jetzt richtig eine schöne große platte
an ihr könnt natürlich auch
portionsweise auf einem ganz normalen
kleinen teller anrichten
aber ich bin so eine große platte
richtig schön es kommt erst der joghurt
darunter als bats sozusagen
[Musik]
und da kommen jetzt die röllchen mit der
schnittkante nach oben hinein
[Musik]
darüber kommen mit den paparazzi
es gibt da jetzt noch ein bisschen
getrocknete minister darüber richten
noch einen kleinen teller für murat an
und dann darf er mal probieren
[Musik]
und bei frauen zu unternehmen
das ist eine alte osmanische mütze jetzt
mal auch auf türkisch videos keine angst
zu haben wir jedenfalls beide sein
kostüm wird uns eigentlich anziehen
wahrscheinlich zu kochen und zu
probieren genau aber naja schade jetzt
mal so lang aber heißen
ok passt euch jetzt gehören erklärt habe
dass gleich muss ich gar nicht mehr zu
essen also bisher ein fleischgericht
kebab ist nicht nur dünner döner kebab
sondern alle fleischgerichte und das ist
ja zu frank käber wahrscheinlich wird
auch mundgerecht zugeschnitten
das hat mich so ein bisschen am tier
litt das von euch wird auch mit yoga
gemacht und gekochtem fleisch und gemüse
und fleisch brühe ist gut
wie ist die konsistenz
eigentlich ist vergleichen möchte könnte
etwas vergleichen oder amerikanischen
die adresse ein bisschen manche
vergleichen wobei ich finde es jetzt bei
manches mehr so fester und mehr übrig
und hier ist es mehr als gut wird ja das
objekt und blätterteig mit intakt
ja genau
es lag ja zum nachmachen empfohlen auf
jeden fall machen es nach
das sultan ist glücklich das sultan ist
glücklich dann wenigstens auch bei
gesunden karawane zieht weiter der
sollte
hast du hast ja recht verstand er duscht
technologisch traktors die karawane
zieht weiter der sultan hat bloß nicht
ich dachte man die karawane zieht weiter
der sultan der dusche nein egal
ok wenn also das rezept findet ihr auf
sase - blog.de viel spaß beim nachmachen
und diese macht es auf jeden fall nach
ist es um macht du guckst die große
platte an sich nicht für dich die
richtig gleich fürs foto an
[Musik]
nächste spital schon jetzt auch noch
geglaubt
butt passen schockt ja gehts in den
keller
tschüss machten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einfach sehr ins detail meine freundin
sabine und ich wir hatten ein richtig
schönes mittels wochenende in
großbritannien da gab es richtig tolle
köstlichkeiten ich möchte die
urlaubsgefühle wieder zurück banken um
ihre freundin zu überraschen mag sally
buch very british eine königliche
theater und gebäck bei der bitte steht
dafür muss ich tatsächlich einfach sally
sonntag 16 uhr bei vox